what could be greater than a king a hero
the aquaman reviews are in we saw it and
we can finally discuss our feelings and
decide are we okay with this of course
the movie is out December 21st so this
is generally gonna be a spoiler free
conversation but let's talk it out
joining me today GameSpot's mike rizzo
and colliders perry Nemiroff thanks guys
for being here and are we okay with this
Mike I have some complaints but I am ok
with Aquaman I am okay with Aquaman I
have many complaints but I'm happy they
took a big swing and at least tried to
do something different you know I am
okay with Aquaman but I have some
reservations I have some things that
didn't work for me but overall I liked
it what were your general thoughts when
he walked out of the theater my main
thought when I walked out of theater was
that was insane I bother I can't believe
how crazy was the scale that they shot
for when you say they took a swing like
they really took a swing and like there
are space battles underwater that feel
as big as anything in Star Wars there
are dinosaurs in this movie and no one
ever mentions it like I like that stuff
I think this is the only mover you can
be like later dude and ride away on a
freaking organ I thought that was
awesome I almost wish they went in more
on that crazy stuff how'd you feel so my
kind of thing I love silly zany fun and
for whatever reason it just never
clicked with me so we've met Aquaman
Arthur curry before in Justice League
how do you feel like he held a movie of
his own Jason Momoa as charisma is
undeniable I don't think it matters
whether you like Aquaman overall or you
don't like it as a moving when you watch
him there is something about that charm
and says he brings to the role that just
completely melts your heart
he just has like this presence whenever
he's on the screen there's that moment
early on when he's in the submarine it's
like one of the first scenes and in the
middle of a fight he just in slow motion
walks through this cloud of steam for no
great for no reason it's the middle of a
fighting it completely slows it down and
he just walks there and there's a guitar
like that's just like bow down and it
doesn't make any sense but yeah so on
it's just like pure sex for no reason
and I loved it so much his love interest
Mira played by Amber Heard how did you
guys feel about her I thought she did a
pretty solid job I kept noticing that
every time she delivered a line because
a lot of the lines in this movie or just
crazy hmm a lot of the times for
delivery was spot-on there was something
about the overall pacing to me that just
felt stilted so even though I can
isolate their performance and say yeah
you're nailing this he just never came
together yeah you know what melted away
from me about her I thought the wig was
gonna be a lot more distracting than I
was I I felt the same way I was into it
it looked weird like ahead of time when
we were looking at posters and still
shots but like in the movie I totally I
completely bought that that was her hair
somehow how do we feel about the
villains of the movie because there was
several I would say I don't necessarily
think the problem lies in the fact that
there were so many villains I didn't
find that my attention was constantly
jumping from one to the other I liked
all the villains I thought Black Manta
was he's not in it enough I want to see
more but I thought he was great like I
liked him as a character I thought that
Patrick Wilson as King Oram was like so
good like I love Patrick Wilson for me
the conjurer yeah he likes charisma that
Jason Momoa has where I'm like yeah he
has to say yes a lot of really cheesy
dialogue but like every time he talks
like he gets this like searing intense
look in his eyes he's Gor yeah you
believe that he is the king of the ocean
nobody balances intensity and cheese in
this movie better I think than he does
yeah I think he's the pinnacle okay we
hashed it out definitive thoughts are we
okay with this I am okay with Aquaman
okay with it happy other people like it
I just don't fall in that boat I'm
somewhere in the middle of you guys I am
okay with it but I would watch like 17
sequels of this movie um but we want to
know your thoughts what did you think of
Aquaman let us know I'm at ash cross and
where can we find you at P never off and
all over the Collider video YouTube
channel I'm at rogue cheddar and
GameSpot calm until next time guys
[Music]